but that type of integrity on both ends
three-point play for Durant
Warriors 9 for 9 from the field here on
the third nice pass
beautifully done jam it with the push to
Lou Williams to Michael Green bingo
right now migraine sedative
franchise-record incidentally for most
points in a playoff game for the
Huntington at 45 at all the NBA record
is 157 points offensive minded tonight
[Applause]
[Music]
got some cash dropping in the wing
jumper I do and I agree with the
relevant I do because I agree the old
fashioned basketball elections you go to
the parks you play against each other
like he wanted to be competitive as
great knocks one down and the Warriors
came back to win that series and
semi-smooth their BA his guts to go do
some coaching
[Music]
fires it down the same by Vermont Green
ends up in the hands of Wilson Jambo the
Clippers wild shot
if you plan for the last shot get to
take the last shot instead it stammering
it and that is disastrous
is how you handle the end of a quarter
fans have been reawakened they thought
it was over wrap around the heroine oh
the job over Bogut Lou Williams played
by Andre Iguodala got the step and a
beautiful setup for Harrow and that's
what you want you want curry to have to
guard a beautiful except for the left
hand swatted in by Harold that is so
hard to do don't want to give anything
they still get to go home and why the
steal my family took it away from curry
and government and does the rest that
Steve Kerr very upset late Thompson is
back out the floor Williams the Harrell
for calamari calamari a follow Wednesday
on Ilana Wingfield
[Applause]
The Herald Oh guilt our goodness
big time challenge thereby a shot bunker
a place of turn dream on Queen on that
last foul by going swing chairs Williams
on the drive count it and a foul the
collective heart and soul of the
Clippers one of the best at driving and
getting files in and this is what I meet
they can't go to the stage a six-point
lead one of these off balance scores
funky butt over here Lou Williams so
smooth the hang time and I tell you what
now don't you 20 remaining in the fourth
Gill goose Alexander gets it to tell
punch it down is a beast in the paint
smart defensively and he's athletic so
he definitely a catch you and take that
poster home to have his that she said it
right now with the turnovers he's not
happy with the Warrens places low
ryeom's
we're worried about sit down of the game
is tied at 128 as we come up on a minute
remaining at the Ford woodies come on
board away there's curry
ready as 31 his weirdness puts on the
brakes and score Williams went by curry
[Applause]
and on the other end
how about Sam it killed this Alexander
finds him and as a fan I'm thinking wait
a minute keep it in Lou's head keep it a
lose handstand but hey